what are some things you guys have
learned from yo gotti just being
you know he's a boss too man he just
bought a [ __ ] soccer team right you
know what i'm saying like what are some
things that you've already soaked up in
terms of just on
from being you know you're ceo yourself
you know what i mean yeah just being
like you said on on a in a in a boss
aspect
um
i like the way you just kind of fall
back and i'm saying that's the as far
back and and put the put the light on as
artists that's kind of like what i want
to do eventually i get to a point where
you know i feel like i gotta maxed out
musically
i'm saying me i tamper with it dibble
and dabble with it but really put the
the spotlight on my artist and use my
platform
in a in that manner you know anything
that i got going on as far as instagram
is concerned or outside of instagram he
immediately bruh send that to me let me
throw that up and uh you know just being
independent we throw everything up it's
it's very rare that
i'm seeing me we got like somebody
that's pumping it pumping it and so uh
you know i just let a way that he he he
involved in everything
um
sitting in the meetings
you know when we take a meeting he take
a meeting
um
and it just inspired me as far as like
everything that i want to do with my
artists futuristically you know right
now i'm kind of like super focused on
myself and i'm seeing me just creating a
pathway so they could uh follow suit but
um
eventually i want to get to a point
where um you know i fall back off a rat
and uh just really round my label and um
just tweak on everything outside of rap
and you know he got a lot of good game a
lot of good game of ism every time we
sit down yeah i'm saying it's like i'm
taking notes a lot of good game ism